معنا الان مراسلنا من هناك عمر الحاج عمر
كل الاطراف تقريبا الروسيه سواء من جانب
فاجنر من جانب الكرمله من جانب المؤسسه
العسكريه تصر على القول ان الجبهه
الاوكرانيه لن تتاثر ابدا بما يجري ولكن
كما قالت كارمن قبل قليل القوات الروسيه
بدلا ان تكون متركزه في المدن الحدوديه هي
تكون متركزه لمواجهه هذا التحرك الجديد من
جانب فاجنر على العموم كيف تنظر كيف وما
هي ردود الفعل حتى الان عمر لديك على ما
يجري تفضل
نعم ليلى ردود الفعل تتراوح بين
الوصف وبين التندر والسخريه مما يجري في
موسكو من هذا ما الذي سميته بالقتال
الداخلي ولكن لابد من الاشاره الا للهجوم
العنيف الذي تعرضت له اليوم الذي اودى
بحياتي ثلاثه اشخاص
وجرحي العشرات واحداث هذا الدمار الهائل
وهذا واحد من الهجمات الكبرى التي تصنف
منذ شهر
هذه هجمه ربما الثامنه الكبرى بهذا الاثر
التدميري الكبير وسط العاصمه اعلم ان
الحديث كله عما يدور في موسكو ولكن لابد
من اشاره الى هذا الحدث الجلل وان سماء
كيف تعرضت لاكثر من 20 صاروخا كما قالت
قياده القوات الجويه وايضا مسؤولين في
كييف تمكنت من اسقاط العديد من هذه
الصواريخ ولكن حطام احد هذه الصواريخ كما
شاهدتم قبل قليل سقط في هذا التجمع السكني
ما زلت
هو الناتج لهذه لهذا الهجوم ان هناك
المزيد ربما سيحدث خلال الساعات القادمه
ولكن الملحوظ ان الرئيس لم يعرج عن هذا
الموضوع لم يتحدث عنه تحدث عن شؤون مختلفه
تماما عما يجري في روسيا كذلك الامر
مسؤولين كما ذكرت قصه الامر على مستشار
الرئيس وايضا متحدث باسم جهاز الاستخبارات
رئيس وزير الدفاع او حتى رئيس الوزراء او
اجهزه اخرى لم تعلق على هذا الموضوع ربما
ربما
الامر اقتصر على مستشار الرئيس الذي كما
ذكرت يتحدث عن وصف مع يجري في روسيا وكيف
توسعت في مناطق سيطرتها وتقدمت باتجاه
رستوف ومناطقه اخرى ثم عاد بعد ذلك
للسخريه مما يجري ولكن يبدو ان المقاربه
الروسيه هي اشغال الاوكران بانفسهم ان صح
القول عبر هذه الهجمات نحن نتحدث عن
اربعين صاروخ في المناطق الجنوبيه هناك
هجمات من البحر سنه بشكل كثيف جدا وفقا
لما تتحدث به قياده الجيش الاوكراني هنا
كيف كانت من ضمن من ضمن مناطق التي
استهدفت اوديسا كريفيري دينيبرو وكذلك
الامر في المناطق الشرقيه السلطات ما تحذر
من هجمات محتمله كما ذكرت ربما اشغال
الاوكرانيين في الجبهات هذه المقاربه
الروسيه والتفرق لما يحدث هناك عدا عن ذلك
التعليقات الروسيه الاوكرانيه حتى الان
هي فقط من مستشار الرئيس اضافه الى متحدث
باسم الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه وحقيقه تصعيد
يعتبر مقارنه بالايام الماضيه خاصه هنا في
كييف هذا الهجوم الذي
جاء عند الساعه الثالثه تحديدا كما ذكرت
استمرت الحرائق هنا لاكثر من ساعه ونصف
حتى تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخمادها وبعد
ذلك اعلن عن سقوط ثلاثه قتله وايضا عشرات
الجرحى وهذا الدمار الذي تشاهدونه خلفي في
الصوره يعني مره اخرى اشغال الاوكران
بانفسهم والتفرغ لما يجري في روسيا على
هذه المقاربه الروسيه ولكن ربما سيكون
هناك تغيير في المشهد خلال